Cheers
feuds demands and resignations we look
at all the recent rumors surrounding the
Duchess of Sussex ET breaks down the
difference between fact and fiction
but I also really care about what I do
first up the latest rumor that a second
member of Meghan Merkel's staff has quit
amid reports the Duchess is quote
difficult over this weekend it was
revealed that Meghan is losing yet
another member of staff her private
secretary
Samantha Cohen will be leaving the royal
household when the baby is born this
spring while the resignation part is
true the rumor about Meghan being
difficult
may be skewed a source tells ET the
Duchess has raised eyebrows among staff
for her rather direct approach but
reports there has been an exodus of
other staff is wide off the mark while
you catch on quickly the source adds
that Meghan quote has many loyal aides
that enjoy working with her and are
impressed by her commitment to
humanitarian initiatives and her
openness to learning from seasoned
courtiers and palace staff about royal
protocols people come and people go and
perhaps someone was there just for six
months trial or perhaps their personal
circumstances changed so yes I just take
it all with a pinch of salt
that's Carolyn rabe author of the royal
touch cookbook and former personal chef
to Princess Diana Prince Charles Prince
William and Prince Harry she echoed
similar sentiments to ET when asked
about the recent rumors plaguing the
Duchess and her staff it megan's finding
her face as well it's a massive massive
change for her to make from the kind of
lifestyle she was leading in the States
as an actress and the freedom to do and
say as she wanted to do and a lot of
clinic restrictions and protocols within
the royal household so I'm sure she's
still learning as well but yeah I didn't
I didn't give it a second thought
according to rob rumours about the royal
family aren't a new phenomenon and I
used to get really frustrated on behalf
of their Royal Highnesses when I worked
there because obviously I'd see what was
written in the papers a lot of the time
what was spread all over the media it's
those kind of headlines that that
interest people everybody is
just wants to know every last detail
about Katyn about Megan and it's really
unfortunate that brings us to the
reported view between the sisters-in-law
working as family does have its
challenges of course does everybody hear
the fact that one's laughing our source
says that much like any family there
have been ups and downs in the Windsor
households adding that William Kate
Harry and Megan don't always agree but
according to royal expert Katie Nichol
it isn't really Kate and Megan who are
fighting Megan and Kate of making an
effort to get along they may not be the
best of friends they don't have that
much in common but actually the real
feud is between the brothers apparently
Harry is upset that he didn't get
Williams full backing at the start of
the relationship so while no family is
perfect even the Fab Four those rumours
about Megan well they're simply not all
true
[Music]